[Music]
what are what are your thoughts right
now
on all this crypto mania i mean there
are differences
huge differences between right now and
2017.
sure namely the entry of
at least one of them is the entry of
institutional investors yes and
just a few months ago paul twuder jones
and
some other legends kind of dipping their
toe in the water
and beginning to make some allocations
in their portfolios uh fund portfolios
which is a big difference not just
personal
i believe that's true somebody can fact
check me but
what do you make of all this this is a
terrain that you're
much more familiar with than yeah i am
well
his my take is that with any
new crazy wild idea uh
come just a ton of skeptics as as there
should be
and when bitcoin was was first launched
and we were all playing around with
the very early wallets and i remember
just buying coins and picking them up
and i wasn't
really early early like i wasn't you
know in the pennies
but i was buying them around 10 12 a
coin something like that
and uh you know it was it was the wild
west it was
very difficult to do anything to
to buy crypto to um you know we were all
setting up mining rigs back then
and trying to mine our own bitcoin and
then eventually pools came out so you
could join in with other people to do it
more efficiently
but this is fresh new technology they
hadn't been hammered and beaten on
and so you know anytime there's
something
that um is directly linked to
your finances uh it takes years
or decades for people to get comfortable
with a new emerging technology to where
they'll
commit any serious capital to that
technology so
i think largely what we're seeing here
is well one it's it's
you know there's a lot of stimulus money
hitting the market there's a lot of
people buying on square cash app there's
you know it's much easier to purchase
bitcoin
than it has ever been you know it used
to be you have to go to
some shady exchange somewhere hold up a
picture of your
driver's license with like literally
your like date written underneath it to
make sure it was you
like shady stuff that i've been on some
of the exchanges my
identification has since been hacked on
many of these exchanges
thankfully i don't live at any of those
addresses that i had those ideas i was
holding up in front of the camera
but i do get text messages of people
trying to fish me all the time
like trying to like get me to like so
creepy it's crazy it happens at least
twice a week it's insane
because my my information is out there
so whatever but
the point being is that it was extremely
difficult to get
um to purchase bitcoin and now you know
paypal came online
just a couple months ago and is offering
the ability to purchase bitcoin and
ethereum directly inside of paypal like
it's just insane how easy this is now
so you're unlocking massive customer
bases like hundreds of millions of users
with paypal you know square cash is the
i think the second or third largest
buyer now
of of bitcoin um that's on the retail
side
right this is just on the retail side
yeah so that's not even talking about
the institutional money going in right
so
you know i work at trueventures uh
venture capital firm
several billion dollars under management
we have positions in bitcoin
you know we've been doing that for a
while um so when you say you guys have
positions in bitcoin that means you've
invested in startups that focus on
bitcoin no that means we actually
own bitcoin how does that work
as a venture capital fund you're
operating the private endowment
yeah i mean every fund is a little bit
different um
you know in our specific case there we
have allocated
as part of our um you know formation
documents for the fund
a certain percentage of the fund can be
in cryptocurrency or cryptocurrency
related companies
so we can say i i'm just throwing out a
random number i i'd have to go look at
the docs see what the actual number is
but let's just say
10 15 of the fund overall fund size
you know we have 600 million plus fund
that's you know that you can only invest
that much from this specific fund into
cryptocurrency
and so uh you know if we're going to go
into and do a purchase
typically dollar cost average your way
in over a couple months and
and and buy in and in a place that that
has
really strong security like we don't
hold this ourselves it's not at our
office
like you're using like there's there's
big financial houses like fidelity and
coinbase custody and others that now
provide these types of services
you don't just have a bunch of hardware
wallets sitting in your jacket pocket
yeah it's uh right here
just in my house um no i don't i
actually i don't i don't mess with that
stuff anymore i used to have wallets and
and i actually had a laptop that i would
i bought specifically for cryptocurrency
and i wanted to keep it in cold storage
meaning that
i back in the day when i was doing the
craziest like
coins you've never heard of on these
weird exchanges i
i went out i bought a laptop it was an
apple
um hooked it up to the internet did all
the software updates
like just put the wallets on there
transferred the funds and then
immediately powered it down so that it
wouldn't be online anywhere
hackable and then put it in a safe and
like that was the way i kept my
cryptocurrency yeah it's crazy but
but yeah so there's been enough time has
gone on this current run-up though is
just
nuts i mean the thing you have to do
with all these things is just
don't look at the the last three months
because it looks like a decent graph
you're like oh that looks reasonable
maybe i should buy something
like this look at that yeah zoom into
the five-year view the 10-year view
that's when you see
really what's happening here and it's
it's not even like a hockey stick it's
like it's
it's even more it's like insane how the
run-up has been and so i get
nervous when you see
you know it's it's always a good towel
around
well in this case it was like the the
virtual christmas or thanksgiving dinner
when uncle harry is asking you if they
should be buying bitcoin like
that's when i like my my spidey sense
tingles a little bit and be like huh
everybody wants this now you know and
there's it's just i
i i wouldn't be if if i were going to
enter the market now
i would do it in a way that is you pick
the dollar amount let's say it's a
thousand dollars and this is not
investment advice i'm just telling you
what i would do
pick a thousand dollars i would say okay
i want to own bitcoin i believe in the
future of bitcoin
i think this isn't going away which all
those things are true and there are
things that i believe
uh it's a proven technology now um let's
take that thousand dollars and invest it
over six months and so just divide it up
by six and this do those i'll say the
first of every month and just go in
doesn't matter what the price is you
don't care you just buy that set amount
and that way you know at least you're
averaging your way in over over six
months
how do you personally think about crypto
for yourself
as part of your portfolio or percentage
of your total
i mean you're kind of famous for telling
not famous well you're famous to me for
telling me when i should buy stuff and
then not telling you when you've sold
stuff
which i pre which i appreciate uh so i
love that call by the way you're like
are you still holding this i'm like no i
sold it for like a 10x like six months
ago and you're like
i'm down or something bad will happen
we've been screwed by the fact that we
didn't talk yep that happens
with some fair frequency but uh what is
uh
what what is your current thinking in
terms of cryptocurrency
are you steering clear do you use do you
still have a certain position
is it an investment for you is it an
insurance policy for you some people
have
drawn that distinction just sort of
philosophically as looking at
cryptocurrency as a
insurance policy hedge i think that over
time
as uh well a few things one
let's just talk about the ecosystem in
general i think that 99
still today of the coins that you see on
the market out there
are just garbage i think a lot of them
and it's hard for them really to go away
they're just the volumes of the volume
and trades that happen just decrease
over time but they still have these
you know somewhat impressive looking
market caps just sitting out there
very stagnant developers kind of drop
off it's just kind of like they're left
for dead but they're still around
so there's a lot of that um a lot of
interesting
innovation happening in the kind of
decentralized finance space so they call
it like defy
it's mostly happening on ethereum uh
so there's there's a handful of projects
where i say that's really interesting
it's almost like an
angel investment now i want to hold some
of that
but with the understanding that this
could go to 10
of the value it is today and so
extremely high risk
but you know still has the ability to
have a 50x
upside right so or at least a 20 or 30x
upside
i if you just look at the market cap of
a bitcoin today
there's not another 20 or 30x anytime
soon coming to coming to bitcoin it's
just
too big right like the market cap is
just too large you'd be
why do you now what how do you come to
that conclusion well i mean
first of all there's a few ways you can
do it i think that you just have to look
at the market cap in general which i
don't have in front of me right now but
i can
i can type it in um the other thing
is just look at the proxies for this so
like what is the market cap of gold
right of all gold out there and it's in
the trillions uh
let me see here so bitcoin right now
the market cap is 82.49 billion
so you know where would we be at if
that's a
10x from now like i mean that's just
insanity that's that's
i i can't imagine that happening anytime
soon it would just be no that's insane
because
of that because that you might put next
yeah i mean apple is worth two trillion
right and so you know you just kind of
have to
and i know it's not the same in that
we're not talking about
um corporations here with with you know
cash flows and pes and things that we
would typically use to
to to value a company that is not this
the closest
proxy that i think most people draw the
comparison to is to just
gold you know what what is how much gold
has been mine how much is do we believe
is there in the in the earth
what are people holding for an
investment how much of it is actually
being worn like there's a lot of other
ways
so there is a lot of potential upside in
in bitcoin but
for me i it's not that i wouldn't hold
it i
would definitely hold it i think it's
going to be a rocky bumpy ride given the
run-up that's had recently
like it's been forever like this has
always been the case of bitcoin it's
been very
bumpy but the new low is higher than the
last
low and it just continues to kind of
like it wouldn't surprise me to see this
drop down to
25 or 30 again but i don't think it's
going to get back to 10.
and there's just too many institutional
buyers coming in so
um you know i like it because there are
a lot of governments the u.s included
are probably one of the biggest
defenders just printing money right now
it's really hard to understand what the
value of a dollar is or what it will be
in the future
this is a fixed number of
coins forever that will never change um
it's becoming it's universally accepted
you know
even more so every month uh all over the
world so
it's it's kind of a global reserve
currency that i i'm comfortable with so
i i do like it for that
you